[Music]
all right let's go
and we are black
hey majo
i think
the time has come for us to diversify
our openings a little bit
let's return to what we started
the initial speed run with which is an
accelerated dragon knight c6
d4 c takes d4 and g6 let's play an
accelerated dragon it's been it's been a
long time
and
i just want to remind everybody of you
know the basic ideas the accelerated is
what i recommend to most people in this
rating range it's a great gateway into
other sicilians because it's really easy
to understand
comparatively speaking
isn't quite as much theory
um and the ideas are very clearly
defined so essentially we're putting
emphasis on developing very quickly and
in the first couple of moves are
supernatural so here we play knight f6
and get our knight out and depending on
what white plays
we either castle or we play d6 or
sometimes we go for d5 and one fell so
bishop c4 okay so bishop c4 we continue
our development by castling notice that
i'm not actually pushing my d-pawn out
just yet uh in order to preserve maximum
flexibility and this shines through in
case white castles
uh you will see why we don't play d6
straight away knight d e2
okay that is
a bad move i think
and we have a way to challenge white
immediately if we want to now we could
play d6 it's not a terrible move but we
could play d6
but if we really want to be
challenging if we want to be testing
what move can we consider here
and and this is something that you
should always pay attention to when your
opponent is a bishop on e3 this is just
an automatic thing that that you you
have to be aware of
from you know out of the corner of your
eye
nobody has named the movie yet i'm very
surprised you guys
aren't thinking in this direction knight
g4 yeah knight g4
knight g4 can be really nasty because if
the bishop moves
how can we follow up how can we put
pressure on f2 and b2 at the same time
and when the c pawn is gone good job for
us when the c bond is gone this is
another thing that you should be
fully aware of at all times
this is a move that is often very nasty
and that's queen b6 not bishop d4 that
blunders a bishop but the right idea
queen b6 hitting the pawn on f2 hitting
the pawn on b2
now this comes with its associated risk
because we're actually not developing
the light squared bishop just yet so
this could backfire on us but i don't
somehow i don't think it will i think
this will turn out okay
this is a fork there's a garden variety
double attack against dupont
which of the pawns should white defend
well probably white should defend f2
but
uh we're gonna take the other one we're
gonna take b2
and how do i know that the queen is not
gonna get trapped well first of all it's
very hard to trap the queen on b2 in
general especially when it has
retreating square on a3 which obviously
is where we want to go with a3 and the
queen has a lot of different avenues of
escape that's the bottom line
the queen has a bunch of different ways
that it can
escape the attacks of white's pieces
through a5 or c5 and in general when
you're trying to judge whether the queen
you know whether to take let's say a
pawn on b2 this is how you have to think
about it okay what are the queen's
escape routes and can those escape
routes be
taken away in one move and here the
answer is clearly no i mean the queen
has too many too many ways that it can
escape
so
i don't know if white's getting that
much activity for the pawn i mean where
exactly is white's activity i feel like
we're pretty solid 95 our opponent
though playing very very well i think
this is this is definitely the best move
and we have to be
cautious here
obviously because there's
there's there's ideas and there's
pressure how should we go about
consolidating here well there's a couple
of approaches that that we could take
one one idea is to bring the screen back
to civilization with queen c5 another
idea is to bring the queen back to d6
unfortunately that blunders the queen
due to knight takes c7 shack
on a similar
note knight g to e5 looks like a really
good move because it gets the knight
back from g4 where it's a little bit
loose and it did its job there i i like
knight g5 and it hits the bishop and it
gets the knight into the center it does
a lot of good things at once and in in
the event of rook b3 we always have the
c5 square for the queen notice that it
is important for the queen for the time
being to be guarding the e7 pawn queen
d66 threatened mate but knight takes c7
as a check and it removed the defender
of the queen so queen d6 would have lost
the queen bishop b3 okay now we have to
identify what it is
about this position that's not
permitting us to consolidate fully what
are the annoying aspects of white's
position well if we pose the question
that way we would love to play a move
like d6 right we'd love to play d6 and
open up the light squared bishop that's
pretty logical but we can't do that
because d6 intercepts the queen's
defense of e7 and it blunders the pawn
on e7 that's not great so we could play
b6 and try to fianchetto but that
doesn't really
cure the underlying disease here which
is that white's got these two incredibly
strong pieces and i think we need to
chase at least one of them away and
possibly even both with a later e6 let's
start with h6 that's the most flexible
move depending on where the bishop goes
we will decide on the subsequent course
of action i actually think we should go
g5 let's just chase that bishop away all
together this will greatly
unburden our position allow us to
consolidate more freely bishop g3
now we can play d6 now that move is
possible e7 is pretty well defended we
can also try to play e6 but you guys
know that i'm i'm very reticent about
combining g6 and e6 because it weakens
all of these dark squares in our
position so
i don't see the need to chase this
knight away just yet i think we should
start with d6 and i'm not worried about
i know some of you are probably thinking
knight c7 looks scary but it's not we
just go rook b8 and and there's no
follow-up if we had a rook on e8 yes
that would be a fork
but it's not what about okay h4
good move
so our opponent trying to open up the
king which is exactly what white should
do here
um let me think about this for a second
this is not going to be an easy game
let's see so queen c5 takes takes queen
d2
this isn't actually a phenomenal move
i underestimated it to be honest with
everybody
okay let's go
let's go bishop g4 let's get our bishop
out
let's get our bishop out
now the reason i didn't want to go g4
and maybe somebody could explain to me
by the way our opponent is disconnected
but
why didn't i want to go g4 what is that
yield what does that allow
why not g4 well g4 weakens a bunch of
squares that white can occupy with his
knight so g4 there's knight f4 and then
knight h5 and that gets incredibly nasty
you see what i'm saying that that f4
square becomes weak it becomes a base of
operations for white's knight
and i just don't like the look of that
not that i love the look of this
and
i i underestimated white's attack here
i'll be full disclosure but that doesn't
mean we're checkmated
there's a long way to go before before
we get checkmated here we have a bishop
on g7 that's excellently placed
for the defense
and
we also still have the possibility of
going e6 and chasing this knight away
from d5
windy two good move
okay
now
will will we have a couple of approaches
here i i think we have a really
interesting move
we have a really interesting way we can
go queen down to a5
and try to force the queen trade but
there is a tactical problem with the
move queen a5 does anybody see what that
tactical problem is
we're still going to play it we're still
going to play it even though it contains
an issue
yeah knight takes e7 check is possible
but if you calculate a little bit
further knight takes e7 check
we go king h7 and because we're
attacking white's queen and we're also
attacking the knight i think that forces
the queen trade so we give back our
extra pawn but at the very least we're
not going to get checkmated now knight
takes c7 check you might be like wait
doesn't that blunder the knight well no
look this knight defends the queen okay
our opponent doesn't do it
our opponent goes queen e3
which is kind of music to my ears now i
think we have an opportunity
to
either go queen c5
yeah i actually think queen c5 might
force the queen trade
i actually think this might force the
queen trade because
well i guess it doesn't i guess i guess
why does queen back to d2
but now our queen is nicely centralized
and white's queen is tied down to the
knight
so after queen d2 we could probably
already go e6 yeah let's go e6 and chase
the knight away
oh this guy is good
kind of a weird game it's like
a weird structure maybe i shouldn't have
gone upon hunting
i i had a bad feeling about it but i
decided to do it anyway
if knight e3 happens we have a pretty
sexy move there i think
so start thinking about what black's
options are after knight e3 i'll show
all of the tactics after the game i know
there's a lot of stuff here that's a
little confusing to people
just bear with me i'll show the the
tactical lines after the game here we're
focused during the game we're focusing
on you know the moves that are actually
played so don't worry about it
knight e3 okay i think we have a really
cool move here really cool move here and
it's not just a a gimmicky move that
that you play because it looks cool i
actually think it does something no
queen e3
bishop f3 yeah i think bishop f3 is the
move now the bishop is untouchable
because of the fork but the point is
very simple we're attacking e4 and we
just want to take another pawn we want
to take the pawn on e4 so this pawn is
not easy to defend
because we have such a nice knight on e5
and the knights are supporting each
other normally bishop takes c5 would be
a reputation but here the other knight
just replaces it and once again the
bishop is untouchable so this move makes
sense
bishop f3 posing more problems
obviously we have to take back otherwise
our whole king side is shattered
yeah knight c3 does technically defend
the pawn but it brings the knight onto a
tremendously vulnerable square okay
bishop b5 we play knight e5 this is all
according to plan and now i think we're
in phenomenal shape knight g3 i think
our opponent played correctly here
actually maybe we're not in phenomenal
shape let's see because our bishop might
end up getting trapped this is a funny
situation let's let's take stock of
what's happening here our bishop is not
hanging but obviously as you can
understand if white moves the queen away
then our bishop could end up being
becoming a liability because white will
be able to capture it
so
i'm thinking of a move here
that almost solidifies the bishop
yeah i like the move g4 so this
solidifies the bishop we're preparing to
sacrifice that bishop we're preparing
for a scenario where white can take on
f3 and in that case after knight takes
f3 check at least our knight is going to
be anchored by the pawn the secondary
idea of this move
is to involve the dark squared bishop
and bring it to h6 in order to intensify
the pressure on white's position i don't
know if this move makes sense bishop h6
it pins the knight on e3 you know it
adds heat to the position
wow this is very impressive by our
opponent queen c1
and now our bishop is trapped
our bishop is trapped
but
what do we do in such a situation well
all we can really do
is roll with it and sacrifice the bishop
so let's go bishop h6 as we plan now
originally i said we should take with
the knight but now i've reconsidered
this is a very instructive moment i
think 99 of people would take with a
knight here but we're actually going to
take with the pawn we're actually gonna
take the pawn i feel like the pawn is a
much better attacker here i mean i think
this should make sense to you guys
intuitively although we'll discuss this
more deeply after the game this pawn is
a really dangerous attacker it serves as
an anchor point
for various mating ideas
no i'll explain i'll explain more deeply
after the game it's just that we're in
time pressure
i actually think that we're not worse
here we're down a piece for two pawns
but white's king is in trouble knight g4
that's a great idea to go knight g4 here
another plan is to move the king aside
and then go rook g8 and start attacking
down the g file that's another benefit
of taking on f3 with the pawn we've
opened up the g file and really the only
ones who can benefit from that
this the more i look at this the more
unpleasant this looks right because look
at how nicely our pieces are placed
and this knight on g3 is a really lame
piece it's just sort of sitting there
it's restricted by the pawn
white's also going to lose on time no
this is
pretty high level stuff here
queen e1 so unpinning the queen sorry
unpinning the knight many ways that we
can improve our position here
we can go for king h7 rook g8
yeah i like king h7 i don't see why we
can't go like this get the rook into the
game get the rook into the attack
h7 and rook cheat why not king g sound
because that would block the the g file
we have to physically get the king away
from the g file why not key
because at the very least here the king
is protecting the bishop in in some
eventuality where i don't know why truck
lands on h1 it's a good idea to
to keep the bishop protected and this is
already panic knight c4
this blunders the knight in one move
but the hilarious thing is that we don't
actually need to take it i think we have
a better move than knight takes c4 who
can tell me what it is
and the first thing that i see when
knight c4 split isn't the fact that the
knight is hanging it's the fact that the
f2 pawn is now pinned
okay well what is the f2 pawn defending
well more precisely what is it now not
defending the knight on g3 so we can
start with the intermediate move rook g8
threatening the crushing rook takes g3
check which is basically mate because
once this knight disappears white's king
is left all alone
so i think our we have our eyes on a
prize that's bigger than the knight on
c4
again
not playing automatically and here once
again
is there anything inherently wrong with
taking on c4 no
but
you know
we can just go for checkmate here knight
g4 looks crushing
okay king h3 now
our opponent is seven seconds so we're
obviously going to win on time but let's
try to play objectively
in such positions it's important not to
get overwhelmed by the abundance of
moves you have and to plan
properly what is it that we actually
want to do here so
at least to me
the main idea should be to get the queen
somehow to the king's side
but if you go queen g5 you're not
threatening anything queen g5 looks
impressive but where is the queen going
from there
so i'm seeing a little regrouping where
we get the queen not to g5 but we try to
get it to h6
what's stopping the queen from getting
to h6 well it's obviously the bishop on
h6 so what if we move the bishop first
somewhere
and then we maneuver the queen through
g5 to h6 but if we're moving the bishop
we don't just want to bury it on f8
that's dumb
we at least wanted to participate in the
attack so let's go bishop f4 probably
not the only move but i think it might
be the cleanest
e5
oh we also have knight takes f2 check by
the way
there's i don't think there's anything
wrong with rook g5 i think that's also
winning
and knight takes f2 check
basically ends the game i think so a
couple of things to discuss we went back
to the accelerated dragon which i
haven't played for a while
great opponent 92 i'm not familiar with
at all
and it may be that in retrospect we
should just go like d6
it is there is one game here in the
database that i see maybe we should just
go d6 and then like
you know i'm not going to delve too
deeply into the into the ideas of this
position because this is a whole
separate thing and you can find a lot of
that in my first speed run
but you know a6 b5 is is possible here
or bishop d7 rook c8
yeah the merozzi is good against the
accelerated but
it's not like it refutes the accelerated
dragon
and most people at like at sixteen
hundred level don't really play the
moratzi but we decided on something more
principled knight g4 bishop g5
queen queen b6
castles
this by the way might be a good game to
analyze with the engine let's analyze
this game with the engine i'm going to
make an exception to the rule
and mostly it's because of how
complicated this game is and i know that
there are a lot of mistakes so
i think it's a it's a pretty good idea
to to have the engine on at least in the
background for just for this game
something i don't usually
do
okay so the accuracy is decent um
okay so knight g4 is good
queen b6 is good m2 is good so this
actually the computer approves of this
knight d5 is a mistake
and this is a very bad move knight g5
so it's blunder i think is a pretty
strong word so because the position is
still equal after a knight g5
the best was to play let's see e6 oh
actually it did want us to play e6
interesting
yeah i was worried about knight c7
rook b8 and i was very worried about
giving up the d6 square like knight b5
ah but now here we just have queen c5
and this is a fork
we're just forking the two bishops here
yeah this i missed i forgot that the
bishops are undefended
so
yeah we're actually threatening queen c5
which is a fork and white's pieces are
all discombobulated
so the simple e6 essentially ended all
of white's
compensation um
but this isn't a blunder knight g5 is
not a blunder it's a mistake and this is
why i hate
i hate using engines because people
don't understand what a blunder is
wonder is when you actually
you know blunder a queen or blunder a
piece
knight g5 is more like a serious mistake
um not that the semantics matter but
there is a distinction
and and people overuse the term blunder
oh magnus blundered geary blundered when
it's just like a relatively small
accuracy
so bishop b3
h6 okay bishop h4
g5 the computer likes the way we play
this d6 it doesn't like
um i guess d6 is overly committal i mean
again i see that the computer wants us
to go for e6 queen c5
wow knight c1 for some reason and now e6
i guess i i went by general principles
here a little bit too much i just didn't
want to play e6
and and weaken the d6 square like this
so
let's see what the problem is with d6
so ah f4 f4 is very nasty for black i
saw this move i didn't think that
frankly i didn't think this was that bad
but now that i look at it and then it's
coming into h5
queen's potentially coming to g4
although not the moment
yeah and somebody proposed the move a5
that's best in this position
oh no it's not best it says to mistake
that's weird it's giving a5 here but
once you play it it reassesses it
now this is an exceedingly complicated
position a4 bishop c2 bishop g4
this is literally anybody's game
but i guess the computer's point is that
black's king is is very very weak here
but not conclusive at all not conclusive
at all so f4 was strong
instead h4
was played
bishop g4
not terrible but not great e6 once again
i just didn't want to make this move
that's the bottom line
this forces the knight back no but here
i thought white had knight c7
rook b8 and once again i thought he had
knight b5 but now we just go queen c5
knight d6 rook d8
and we trap the knight so
again
my reluctance to play e6 was not not
good in this game
okay so bishop g4
yeah it is shallow but it's it's good
enough to to give us a general
impression of
it's good enough to give us a general
impression of of the game right we're
not really using the engine to
to like do anything crazy
i'm gonna set it to unlimited
the engine is obsessed with these six
okay so here
wow it wants us to take gh that's a
ridiculous move
bishop h4 but this just shows you how
complicated these positions are it's
almost impossible to play the top
computer moves here
so queen a5 yeah white should have gone
97 check
and and gone for this end game where i
knew that black is probably worse but i
thought this was the best outcome
given how dangerous the position is
um
so queen e3
queen c5 is good
e6 is good and bishop f3 is not bad
but it wants us to play the more simple
g takes h4
bishop e2 for some reason and knight d4
just going for the activity of the
knights
but this is a great example again of why
i don't like using engines i'm very i
was very happy with the bishop iii and i
think this probably deserves an x-clam
whereas some other moves i made that the
computer doesn't say are a mistake
might objectively speaking be
uh worthy of criticism
so for instance bishop f3 i still think
is a good move
and and that's why you should always
take
you know these computer assessments of
the grain of salt
this should be five is a great move yeah
so here our opponent found a really
strong idea bishop b5 and knight g3
and the bishop is somehow trapped on f3
which is pretty crazy
if we go bishop g4
then f3 traps the bishop once again
that's the problem
so i found g4
which is not phenomenal oh my goodness
knight ef5 existed
knight ef5 e takes f5 and now queen g5
jesus and then all of a sudden white is
jumping in with all of his pieces
it's still not so clear bishop g2 oh my
goodness
no the computer needs to sit here i mean
this is such a complex position
because now the point is queen f5
there's knight h4 check
we nh5
what the hell is going on fe4 bishop d5
knight h4 check
this is craziness king h1 queen d4
so it looks like white is better here
just because of the initiative
but completely irrational complications
so 90 f5 was very strong why not knight
takes f5
ah because of just bishop takes c4 and
now we're able to win just white's
initiative evaporates here but this move
queen g5 very impressive delaying the
movement of the knight
and so this is why again you're seeing
again and again like why
engines suck bishop h6 is a nice move
yeah and here
gf3 is very strong so here's the reason
why
uh
if you play knight takes f3 you're
allowing king g2 and it's actually
counterproductive to allow king g2
why is it counterproductive because
white is now ready to play rook h1
and once white gets the rook to h1 white
just assembles more beef on the king
side it gets harder and harder to do
anything to white's king on the other
hand if you think about g takes f3 this
keeps the king locked in
keeps the king locked in king g2 is
impossible
and that pawn is a thorn and is a bone
in black's throat it's just like not
possible to coordinate the pieces here
even though gf is not a check
um it's it's a much more long-sided move
than taking with the knight
and now yeah king age seven
yeah and this is already this is already
checkmate so rook g5 some people are
asking is this good
it's not that convincing actually
it's apparently not that convincing
knight d2 and a lot of you wanted to do
this
but amazingly after king takes g4 white
escapes
this is a ridiculous position but look
at this the king is escaping through f3
this is not mate
this
is
you're wrong on one thing this is not
meth
um this is not mate king takes f3
there's no way to defend this pawn
i always say the king hunts are the
hardest
uh thing about attacking king hunts are
incredibly treacherous
um and a lot of people just assume that
anything is made but the king is a
ridiculously slippery piece
it's a breaking bad reference
um
so you have to be very disciplined i
like bishop f4 a lot
and then knight f2
so knight f2 is just another idea of
this move
but
that i mean this game is just incredibly
irrational
and
if if you played a game like this you
know and you analyze with an engine you
might end up with more questions than
than answers um
and more more questions than you even
had initially like what is it that
you're supposed to take away from this
game
um
and well there's a couple of things
right first of all
you know
probably from a purely practical
standpoint knight g4 might not have been
the best i i think it's possible that
just d6 is calmer and
you know a little bit less less crazy
but it's interesting i mean here i think
the main lesson of this game is not to
over apply general rules i'm constantly
hammering home
the concept of not going e6 and g6 i'm
constantly evangelizing and
pontificating about not going e6 and g6
because it weakens the d6 square
tremendously obviously as we as we saw
and largely because white's bishops are
undefended white is unable to exploit
that weak weak square as we saw
if white gets the knight to b5
queen c5 simply wins a piece
concrete considerations always transcend
these you know these general rules
and i
quite frankly didn't even take e6 that
seriously i just thought it was a very
anti-positional move whereas
it was actually the king to the key to
the kingdom to get rid of this knight
asap
by allowing this knight to remain on the
board
on in the center uh
we complicated the task greatly and
you know this could have very seriously
cost us that wiped on f4 and exploded
the king's side
so you know a good a good reminder of
the fact that you know we shouldn't over
apply these general rules but some of
these mistakes i don't think are
are necessarily such a big deal like
queen a5 i mean playing g takes h4 is
very difficult in this position because
that essentially opens up the king side
on our own volition does that sort of
sort of make sense and i think another
instructive moment is is here not
not taking on f3 with the knight you
know refraining from the temptation to
make a move just because it's check
so that's what i have to say
all right guys i think
this is a pretty packed game a lot of
stuff to to go over there and you can
always find this game in my game history
and analyze it on your own
you know this is this applies to people
watching on youtube as well
you know if you're not fully satisfied
by the
level of analysis you feel like you have
lingering questions you can always load
this
on your own and analyze with an engine
and you know extract more lessons that
way so that's what i'll say but for the
time being guys we're gonna call it
thanks for hanging out see you guys
later
[Music]